an English garden in the springtime but
Ukraine's president came to Checkers
Countryside residents of the UK prime
minister for more prosaic matters
weapons and money to continue fighting
Russia and thank you especially special
to you and your government for
supporting us really at this moment like
you said at the moment of challenges the
moment for us for our society our people
especially for our soldiers moment is
tough last week Britain said it would
become the first country to supply
Ukraine with long-range cruise missiles
known as Storm Shadow and just before
these talks started it promised hundreds
more air defense missiles and hundreds
of attack drones right we are here for
the long term we remain steadfast in
wanting to defend Ukraine not just now
to reclaim its rightful territory but
also to ensure that Ukraine has a means
to defend itself into the future as well
before his brief trip to Britain
zelenski visited Berlin as well as Paris
pushing for Ukraine's bid for NATO
membership to be approved as early as
the next Summit in July he's also been
asking for some very specific support
one thing that came up in Monday's talks
was President zielinski's request for
what he called a coalition to provide
fighter jets Rishi sunak said that
Britain would soon start training
ukrainians to fly fighter jets but the
government's made it clear it won't be
providing planes
Moscow predictably is not impressed with
the latest pledges of military aid for
Kiev
this extremely negatively Britain claims
to be among the top countries that
continue to pump weapons into Ukraine I
repeat once again this cannot have any
significant or fundamental impact on the
course of the special military operation
but it all leads to further destruction
Vladimir zielinski knows there's a
growing debate across Europe about how
long Ukraine's war effort can be
supported for now he's hoping the charm
offensives can keep up the pressure on
his Western allies to turn solidarity
into action
Nadine barber Al Jazeera London